uh jake paul is now the biggest opponent
in boxing i don't care what anybody says
i just need you to ask yourself
where you can make more money in boxing
just ask yourself where you can make
more money in boxing i know i was saying
this before i said
canelo's biggest money fight is gonna be
against jake paul most people listening
right now if you're not a boxing fan you
have no clue what weight division canelo
fights in you can't name a person canelo
would even fight you don't know other
people 168 pounds you don't know other
people 175 pounds you don't know anybody
else at 160. the only piece of person
who could probably say it like 160 or
168 might be oscar de la hoya coming
back to fight vitor belfort boxing in
terms of casual fans being interested in
actually knowing fighters i hate to say
this it [ __ ] pains me but it's
[ __ ] dead
it's a shame to say but the average
casual the guy who's coming up the guy
who saw on an undercard and was exciting
no longer exists we're naming guys i
don't think most people can name a box
under 30.
name a boxer under 30 it wasn't on the
jake paul card logan paul ryan garcia
tommy fury no brian garcia oh yeah ryan
garcia there you go ryan garcia now
another guy who came up youtuber or
really he wasn't a youtuber but he
really is a strong social media
he started talking to under 30. jervante
is under 30. but javon and great call
but jervante is too small to fight a
canal yeah right so canelo's biggest
payday before this fight i was like
there's no way there's no way why would
a conor mcgregor fight a jake paul why
would you even do that why would a
canelo fight a j paul why would you even
do that
well now you do it to make money and now
it doesn't seem that crazy matter of
fact
i know i know i know you're saying i
know you're saying crazy no no it's not
crazy it is you can't name another
person in canelo's division we just
recorded this before you [ __ ] up the
video
stat they're stuttering for two minutes
i did because i need to talk to ghouls
exactly
but the fact is most people cannot name
another person to me it's very basic to
get a lot of money you need casual
people to get interested casual people
don't know most boxers they know the
paul brothers whether you like him or
hate him they know him i will pay to see
him lose or i'll pay to see him win but
i will pay either way as a casual so it
doesn't matter and and right now there
is an all-time high that's correct in
terms of wanting to see jake paul get
beaten there's a moment in the fight
okay i don't know if you guys experience
this i don't know how you guys watch the
fight
and i'm just gonna have an honest
reaction yes i'm rooting for this kid
jake bro i'm room for this kid jake the
kid is 24 years old he has the entire
united states parts of the world
watching him and he did that on his own
with his team but he did that he
garnered this level of attention started
boxing three years ago this
motherfucker's been boxing their whole
life they can't get 15 people to show up
to a to a [ __ ] hilton to watch them
box
right
they can't get a local car they can't
get their family to come see them they
can't get 15 cousins to show up to see
him right right there are comics right
now probably hating on jake paul hey you
can't you can't get 30 people in houston
to a show saturday night's busy you know
what i mean like you're in houston like
this club
he did on a sunday
he did that show the lord's day okay in
a [ __ ] arena so let's put some [ __ ]
in perspective the guy the guy knows how
to get eyeballs knows how to get people
to watch give him that regards if you
like them or hate them right now there's
an all-time high for wanting to see him
get beat i don't know if you guys are
watching but when you watch if you did
and everybody at home think about this
as well when tyron woodley lands the
right hand that rocks jake yeah
[ __ ] got excited yeah okay my
girl's off the couch okay i'm off the
couch dove's off the couch we're going
what the [ __ ] is about to happen i'm
room for jake yeah i'm room for jake and
i see tyrone land and i'm like oh [ __ ]
this would be really interesting if the
kid who talks all the [ __ ] ends up
getting clipped in his hometown gets put
down when tyrant didn't take advantage
of the fact that he had him stunned and
then later gets stunned in the round and
then the next round comes out barely
even throws any punches what did i say i
said jake knock this bum out
knock this bum out he had him and he was
afraid he was afraid to try to finish
that fight and you got to give jay
credit for trying to fish it
connor
i'm sorry the biggest money fight conor
has if khabib's not coming out
jake
and i don't even think that connor beats
i don't understand why it's offensive
you're not saying he's the best boxer in
the world he's not even close he's
saying he's the guy that would make the
most money but that's not accurate who
canelo made 15 15 mil his last fight
connor made
seven hundred thou versus um
asking connor made i'm sorry um
paul brother paul paul made seven
hundred thousand but what did he do
canelo made fifteen million that's what
he wanted
more after that with the zone he made 25
to 35 from the saunders fight
who canelo
he made seven hundred thousand dollars
guaranteed versus yeah one came in on
the pay-per-view yeah that's what i
think and canelo took a piece of the
pay-per-view also sure sure canelo has a
guaranteed deal with the zone right
where they think they paid them up front
i think they renegotiated that contract
but it was like you're guaranteed 300
million so i think that what he makes in
those pay-per-views gets chipped away
from that amount of money okay and he's
not saying canelo jake paul will make
more than canelo he's saying whoever
canelo fights whoever he fought to make
15 million if he fights jake paul he
probably can make more than 15 million
way more we'll buy 50 million 75 million
it's like right now people want to see
him get knocked out and i'll be honest
with you canelo [ __ ] him up and canelo
[ __ ] him up easy
it's different it's different but what
jake paul and his team have exposed and
this is the brilliance of him and his
team is
we overrated mma boxing
yeah if they knew this
that we thought okay these guys these
guys are savages they [ __ ] anybody up in
a street fight they will destroy people
but
the skill set that is striking in mma
does not translate to pure striking and
boxing that's true and i've been
thinking about why
and i think the reason is
one
your balance is completely different but
i think a big component about it is
in mma there is no take a punch to land
a punch
in boxing
you've got these gloves on you could
probably take a shot if it means you're
going to land a big one you probably
walk into a couple jabs in mma if
someone lands flush you're going down
so you
train yourself
when you're doing striking you train
yourself to get hit and then not get in
contact land one punch grab them up
throw them to the ground in boxing
that's not the case in boxing i'm trying
to set you up maybe i throw a couple
light ones hit you hard light back to
the body there were times where i saw
jake paul throwing like three four punch
combinations tyron was one punch at a
time the whole time because in an mma
fight that's all he needs yeah he needs
one punch to sit your ass down in his
career he won five ufc championships off
of one punch it could be fair to tyron
if there wasn't ropes he might have got
jake paul with that one punch yeah and
some people might give him what's called
a standing eight count like when it
looks like your drop but the ropes save
you and then some people might have
given that point but he got washed the
whole fight it was ridiculous when he
held his hands up and also how different
are the point structures
like is he thinking about points like is
tyrant in their boxing thing about mma
he's absolutely delusional like when he
raised his hands
into that like when he put his hands in
the air that was the single least
self-aware moment in the history of
recorded television when i saw him go
like this after i didn't even know i
thought i had no you stretching like
what could you possibly what can you
possibly raising your hands in the air
it's what every fight it's whatever yeah
is that just him asserting confidence
like yo i got that [ __ ] even though you
didn't bro one round yeah tops maybe
yeah one round you gotta do that because
it's in the judge's hands so it's like
you have to you have to look confident
yeah
i thought he knew i was like this is my
[ __ ] nose no at the end when he was
talking like
we gotta run that back bubba i was like
what are you doing you know what's so
annoying about the run it back thing
like they made a deal on a deal that
already existed what you mean
if you get the tattoo we'll have a
rematch no
the deal was the deal was that if you
lose you get detached well jake got spun
he got
because he knew that tyron was never
gonna get the tattoo yeah so then he's
like oh here's an option where you're
really gonna get it yeah but [ __ ] that
and i don't even care if he doesn't get
the tattoo i don't need to see that
fight again you had the opportunity i
think logan said it best it was like yo
you had the shot yeah you had to try to
come in here and risk it you didn't risk
it this would happen also in the mma
career it seems like i'm upset at tyron
i am a little
i am a little it might seem this way
it's because i am
if you felt it you're right
it's c i mean like listen he this kid
played you they knew it they [ __ ]
knew it and i think it's one of those
things where it's like we kind of got to
look at ufc or not ufc but mma hands and
mma punching power is different than
boxing punching power very different is
it like tennis and like racquetball or
some [ __ ] like that where it's like yeah
on the surface they seem very similar
but they're really not it's probably
more like football and rugby okay now is
it a testament to the athletes or is it
a testament to how the training is done
just training i think it's just the way
the fight works yeah i think it's just
training i mean there's an argument to
be made you might get better athletes in
mma now right but it's just the training
and i really think it comes down to i
can't get caught
i cannot get caught counter punching and
boxing is pretty effective and mma is so
risky it's super risky there are people
who do it i mean like tyron made his
bones counter punching like he would you
would slip a jab and then he'd come over
with that like big right hand and just
drop people right but like mma you can
connect big grab somebody get them to
the ground while they're stunned keep
pointing boxing is create some distance
and tyron didn't know what to do he had
him hurt keep swinging you see a second
where he lands that big punch and then
he legit his arms go flat and he steps
back do you think these mma guys are
underestimating what boxing requires or
do you think they don't have enough time
to train to get to that level
i think that
they
are underestimating how effective a
reach advantage
and a weight advantage can be in a sport
that they're not comfortable doing
you can mitigate
reach
and
somewhat weight with really good
wrestling yeah you get him in the clinch
like that's it i'm in the clinch i'm
inside
to be able to be like a really good
inside boxer takes [ __ ] decades yeah
so now you're just hoping you land hard
also you're getting tired because you're
not used to throwing this many punches
yeah so now you're exhausted now you're
gonna knock a guy out with limited power
in the eighth round not happening i
think the difference and you spoke to it
earlier is that they've been training so
many years in mma they're not used to
having to throw so many punches because
he didn't he didn't use a jab he didn't
really
counter as much there was no combination
his whole crouch looked off like that
was an mma low ass yeah so it's like the
way he's fighting he wasn't going about
that to win on points he was going about
that hey i just got to get the knockout
he's got to get and that's it i'll be
honest once he hurt go go finish no i'm
just saying that's the reason why these
mma guys who are trying to go into
boxing because once you once you get
tagged or once you get a little tired
then you revert back to all those years
so even though you might have been
training the last three months boxing
it's like you revert back in that ring
to the mma stuff anytime you're in
trouble you go back to what you're used
to and that's why you saw he didn't he
wasn't throwing he wasn't throwing and
it's like he was in there trying to
survive and i'll be honest with you and
this was my concern when he hurt jake
and he kind he didn't drop him but he
dropped him into the ropes that was
enough for him hmm yeah i looked in his
eye i looked at him and i looked at his
posture and looked the way he fought and
i was like oh he thinks he did enough he
got some moral victory he caught him he
clipped him that was a knockdown like it
was enough for the bravado but it wasn't
enough to win the fight
and he didn't press the [ __ ] action